looking shape you're looking good just a
few decades ago being a man was so much
easier according to the ants all you had
to do was make money love sports
oh and stifle any emotions you might
have simple really
thankfully we've come a long way since
then all have we now more often than not
man is shown to be well the idiots Laura
scheduled a playdate for 3 p.m. breed a
dad of twin boys firmly believes gender
conditioning is alive and kicking watch
out he's used to the jokes that come
with explaining he runs yoga classes for
men men are relatively conditioned
around always feeling that they need to
complete you know in whatever field that
they're operating within and that goes I
think for their own minds and bodies
does that sense as though they need to
be able to battle and overcome those
hurdles themselves without reaching out
to others but is it more difficult to be
a man now than in previous generations
in a specially commissioned sky data
poll 50% of men told us they think it is
women were split 39% thought it was more
difficult 39% less difficult we then
asked both genders if they felt issues
facing men are being given more or less
priority than issues facing women 72% of
men said they felt less and 57% of women
agreed Olympic medal winning swimmer
Mark Foster says it's crucial that young
men feel they can open up it took me a
long time to come out and that was
simply because the little voice was
going don't share it's a weakness it's
just that any other and it wasn't
because ultimately I did share things or
so surprised the way that people
responded to me Harvey Weinstein for
some
represents the walking embodiment of
toxic masculinity and in the light of
the me to movement is it rather rich to
expect feminists to celebrate a day for
men we know that men have quite a lot of
power and privilege broadly speaking for
a long time men have been
because society is encouraged that and a
year on I don't feel as though a lot has
changed I've had a look for men being
quite defensive and quite upset I've not
really heard any commitments to men
changing their behavior the fact is we
do need to start talking before these
little boys get bigger with the train
with suicide being the biggest killer of
males under the age of 45 clearly our
narrow definition of masculinity isn't
helping anyone
Katie Spencer Sky News